[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as we bring in the popular analysts from
the mothership dan arlovsky
two-hour nfl live on espn that starts at
three eastern today from cleveland
marcus spears mina kimes
ryan clark laura rutledge and more
espn abc's draft coverage continues
tonight at 7 eastern then all day
saturday beginning at noon eastern i
like the all green yesterday dan bold
statement there who uh
who helped you pick out your suit there
yeah i appreciate that but that was my
wife she picks out
usually my my on television clothes it
was a money day
because it was was a money making day
for these guys so i i went with the
green
what do you have today what's in store
for today yeah a blue
traditional maybe not a traditional blue
but a little bit of a steel blue with a
cream and blue colored tie
some sweet shoes so to end the week a
little bit
more traditional than wednesday and
thursday when i went
kind of maroon and then green okay but
you know
uh herb street has it in his contract
that he gets to wear
blue before anybody else does so i would
i would check
just with management with that dan okay
make sure i don't i don't disrespect
somebody above me i'll do that yes
all right let's start with aaron rodgers
here i'm trying to figure out what was
he hoping to accomplish yesterday
well i don't know if that was aaron
leaking it or not or whatnot i mean if
you
listen to people like schepter talk this
has been something that's going on for a
while now
and it just so happened that it came out
yesterday um
again maybe it was leaked by aaron it
doesn't aaron doesn't
kind of i don't take aaron as that kind
of guy that tries to hijack the draft so
to speak
um i think at the r at the end of the
day
this has been something that started
with x dan like
hey aaron rodgers is unhappy okay and
then he plays
the season he has the season that he has
and then he starts to get more unhappy
because
i'm playing so well but i still we're
still like
a piece away from actually winning the
super bowl so to speak and so that
festers a little bit
and the packers are like we need to
address this so then over the last
month it sounds like maybe six weeks or
so they've gone out to him and said what
do
how can we fix this how can we fix this
how can we fix this and maybe aaron gave
them their chance to try to rectify it
or repair that relationship
and it just so happened that that
relationship has been deemed
unrepairable at least in this moment up
until yesterday
yeah but i don't understand you know
it's one thing to kind of grab the uh
the franchise's attention i think
russell wilson aimed to do that
i don't think russ wanted to be traded i
think he just wanted to say hey
can i at least have a conversation can i
be involved in this
can i can i help in any way this feels
different dan with aaron rodgers
well i because i think this is way
bigger than football dan
i think this is about uh there is a
respect aspect listen every great
quarterback's got an ego we know that
right and so his ego feels a little bit
disrespected
i sent out this tweet last night in
their last 10 first round picks
nine guys have been defense and one has
been the quarterback selected
and i get it like everyone's like well
have you seen our defense in green bay
yeah guys i was in the division for
seven years
but i do think that there comes a point
where
you know last year they chose the future
in the draft the packers
they did so with jordan love and aj
dillon okay
and all aaron's doing right now is
expediting that process
he's bringing the future to the present
and it is because
he was the mvp of the league last year
if he threw for 26 touchdowns or 28
touchdowns
this isn't a conversation but when you
go and do on the field what he did
now he's regained the power so to speak
and so i think there is a little bit of
a relationship
and and ego disrespect
well if the niners are offering you the
number three pick overall
and they're offering you a couple other
let's say a couple other
picks uh or maybe uh i don't know
fred warner i'm like i don't know but
let me just put it out there
if i'm green bay man i listen to
that like if if i think we're moving on
then i go okay like we're going to take
a hit people are going to go hey
how could you let him go well we let
farve go we let aaron go everybody gets
right
you know goes to another like i would do
that if i'm green bay
what about you dan dead on and i've said
that since
last night like just because brian dude
and coos their general manager goes
we're not trading aaron rodgers and
respectfully
guys you started thinking about this
last year
so you should not be surprised you can't
it this isn't that's where it's a very
different situation than seattle because
the whole question was if it's true or
not russell wanted out was who was going
to be the replacement for russell
but green bay already started this
process in their minds
and planning for the future and planning
for jordan love
to take over and so they can't sit there
and go well we're not trading aaron
rodgers
you guys were already planning for life
post aaron rodgers
and you're justif like you can do
whatever you want your general manager
but you can't sit there and go we're not
going to trade them when you
already set this in motion so yeah i
mean it was interesting last night
because i started to think well
if you're san francisco and you don't
have any more assets first round
pick-wise
because you use those to get up like do
you take kyle pitts at three and then
give him bosa kyle pitts and you know
next year's
i don't know or the first round big so
uh but i i don't think that
green bay should sit back and go nope
we're not trading them because
you've already started this thought
process uh we're talking to dan orlovsky
of the mothership
how does this work for the 49ers with
trey lance
um i think it's i'd say this dan i think
it's the greatest flyer
at quarterback in the history of the
first round
when they selected trey lance super
talented super bright
check all that box talk right um
quarterback is a repetition position
the only way you get better and to
really know is
repetitions he's got 118
pass attempts in college it's the lowest
that a first round quarterback has had
in 40 years
okay one guy in the first round in the
last 15 years has had under 400 that's
mark sanchez 480 or 500 487
so i think the challenge for san
francisco is this i think trey lance
needs to get on the field and play
because of what i just mentioned he
needs reps okay
and that's the only way to really
develop is get those reps
now the challenge is san francisco also
has to win football games
you know they've got a losing record
three out of the four seasons john lynch
and kyle shannon who i love
but that's it that is what they are and
so they need to win
they've got a roster to win now the
challenge is
developing a quarterback but also
winning football games is very hard to
do
okay and um a lot of times young
quarterbacks fail because of that burden
because when it gets to when it all
costs
you revert back to old habits and that
stunts your development
and kyle needs to go from great
offensive mind
to really good quarterback developer
uh i i like in the first round to
playing blackjack like you have certain
numbers that you hit on
or in certain numbers where you go i'm
going to stay like
the the raiders always feel like you
know it's
16 and they want to hit like they they
they risk a little bit more
whereas some of these other teams just
sort like the patriots
didn't go up you know everybody said oh
they're going to go up and i said no i'm
told they're not going up they just sat
there they got the guy that they wanted
uh if detroit you know they were patient
with who they want the chargers with who
they wanted
it just felt like the raiders you know
were were a little itchy on the trigger
figure i don't know if there was anybody
i don't know if you agree with me
i i was told by a scout last night
that's the worst first-round pick
you know with alex because you could get
him in the second
it's not him the person player it's it's
you drafted him
where you drafted him anybody else stand
out that way
well i i mean touching on the raiders
two things one they had
one of the top eight offensive lines in
football last year and then they
dismantled it this off season
and then also like your greatest
issue off of football team-wise is your
defense
you know so it's like they they really
created a mess and then try to band-aid
the mess
but left the the biggest gash open still
um i did not like the travis etn pick to
jacksonville
um i think he's a nice player there's no
doubt about that
but i don't think you take a first round
tail back as an organization unless
you're like a
tail back away from a championship right
like a championship contender that's
obviously not jacksonville
a second of all they've got way bigger
holes i mean they actually have in james
robinson
whatever your organization wants yeah an
undrafted really good tail back
you know so it's like what are we doing
and then they signed carlos hyde and
then for urban meyer to come out this
morning and say
well our 1-2 punch is going to be james
robinson
and carlos hyde and travis ctn is our
third round back my mind goes what
because third round tailbacks in the nfl
nowadays the third down our past
are our our past blockers yeah they're
protection guys
old school third round running backs or
third down running backs think of like a
kevin fox
those pass catchers they're used on
first down nowadays
and i just don't understand the thought
process of taking that that pick
for jacksonville at that moment what did
the bears get
oh gosh uh again i think one of the best
picks in the draft you know
the bears got hope um the bears got a
prayer
so to speak i think justin fields talent
is very spectacular
i think the thing that i sit here and
say this morning is
it's on you now maggie to do for justin
fields
what you didn't couldn't and wouldn't
for mitchell trubisky
and i had said that for years is one of
the things that mr trubisky did have
was athleticism he did have and listen
justin's
way more talented than mitchell but they
never allowed mitchell to be an athlete
they never saw okay that's a strength we
gotta do a lot of that stuff
and the reality is that is a strength
for justin fields is his athleticism
so you better find ways to utilize it
and then they never addressed his flaws
or his weaknesses because his flaws and
weakness were mechanics that's the same
for justin
and you better attack that because then
the talent never shines if you don't
and they better not they asked i think
they asked mitchell trubisky to be a
player that he's not
pocket pastor statue guy don't do that
for justin fields don't do that with him
and i think that's if if matt nagy can
sit there look at himself in the mirror
and go i learned from that then
we're talking about something in chicago
but it's all on matt maggie
mac jones to the patriots they didn't
have to go up
they got it blows my mind how how do
they not know or how did they know
like how did they know that matt someone
wasn't gonna jump them
pittsburgh washington the rape somebody
wasn't gonna jump them because i do
think that they like matt jones and i do
think that he can be a really good
player
so how did bill have like such
incredible discipline to just sit there
and know no one's gonna go get him blows
my mind
um i think he's got a chance to be a
really good player there
the eagles had the 10th pick and i was
wondering if they were going to take
justin fields
now i know you have jalen hurts but
i thought washington football team might
go up
and and try to get justin fields like i
there were teams that i and i mentioned
the bears yesterday that i thought that
they could go up i thought pittsburgh
may be interested in in justin field so
like it's one of those where we can talk
we can have mocks
you know we can have conversations in
the war room but when you're on the
clock
and when you got to make a move there
like i can't imagine what that pressure
must be like for some of these teams
where they're going we got to wait
and wait but belichick and his dog
you know maybe they were just chilling
and it's like all right let me uh
let me know when where on the clock yeah
and it's just like
to have the ability to know that's the
player you want
and not get i guess trigger happy is the
phrase or not get in panic mode
and even if it's like hey we got to go
from 15 to 12. or we got to go 15 to 13
because we're worried someone is going
to jump us
that that is what and i and i guess
that's what happens when you've been in
the nfl forever and you've probably
got so many connections that he knew
because there's no way that he doesn't
know and just sits there in my opinion
and and that's what having information
is is such a powerful thing you were
drafted in the fifth round what kind of
draft party did you have when you were
selected
dan i had a depressing one dude like
first of all my draft was
old school so it was two days rounds one
through three
friday and then rounds um four through
seven on saturday or no saturday sunday
excuse me
um i thought i was gonna get drafted on
like the third round the last pick of
the third round i didn't obviously the
last pick the third round was maurice
claret who was coming off of a year of
not playing and had some off the field
stuff
and i got furious i was like how's this
guy drafted and i wasn't
so i hung on the next day shattered my
phone like a child
um you know and was angry and then
finally got the call
wait you broke your phone shattered my
phone when that pic was made
shattered it against the ground which is
stupid hard to get ahold of you the next
day
so i have to go to the rising store the
next morning super early
i'm waiting there for the worker to come
to open up the store get a new phone
my agent's trying to call me and he's
like hey you'll you'll go off the board
sooner that doesn't happen
obviously because i went in the fifth
round so i'm angry i'm bitter
and then finally the call comes it was
coach mariucci who i actually got to see
yesterday mooch
um and it went from like anger to joy
which was awesome celebrated that night
for sure with some friends but um
you know it was a unique one who told
you they were going to draft you and
they
they didn't seattle seattle in the third
round
seattle in the third round called me and
told me
we're drafting you i think it was the
82nd pick if i'm correct
and said we're gonna take you i'm
sitting there watching the television
and they took david green
remember the lefty out of georgia who's
really good in college david green the
lefty quarterback
i don't remember him yeah so not only
did they tell me they were taking me at
82
and didn't but they also took a
quarterback
uh yeah paulie david green never played
a snap in the nfl
yeah i mean a little bittersweet and
then i was sitting there like well i
gotta go so then new orleans took like
um adrian mcpherson and i was like what
the heck
and i think the panthers took stefan the
fours and i'm like
what is it so like 97 quarterbacks went
ahead
kyle orton went ahead of you ko who
and kyle orton's the reason i didn't go
to purdue so when kyle
goes ahead of me i'm like wait i ain't
go to purdue because of orton
i got drafted later than
yeah but who are those guys they're not
on nfl live
yeah right yeah yeah because orton made
a lot more money than me that's why
yeah uh hey great to talk to you have
fun today
and enjoy the weekend thank you dan
thanks bud good to see you that's dan
orlowski espn nfl analyst
two hour nfl live with uh host laura
rutledge uh mina kimes marcus spears
ryan clark and of course stan arlovsky
live three eastern
from cleveland